hi welcome to science handout from
science mission
I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission we
have today dr. su bodasse gupta
assistant professor in oncology and
stress biology from russell park
comprehensive center at buffalo new york
dr. Dasgupta has published almost 20
research articles in repeated journals
like nature Nature communications PNAS
cell reports etc he has also won several
awards and has been awarded several
research grants and is the reviewer in
several journals now welcome Dasgupta so
much can you please tell us about
yourself your background your education
etcetera sure so I I have a bachelor's
in microbiology chemistry and zoology
from Bangalore University in India and I
have a master's in biochemistry from
Department of Biochemistry pandora's in
the University in Varanasi and after
after finishing my master's I had an
opportunity to work for a year in
pharmaceutical industry so I walked in
doctor radius laboratories in Hyderabad
where I was you know I was involved in
drug discovery research and spending a
year there I I joined my higher studies
University of North Texas Health Science
Center at Fort Worth Texas
so got a PhD from the und Health Science
Center in 2010 and then after that I
joined Baylor College of Medicine in
Houston Texas to do my postdoctoral
starts studies and after finishing my
postdoctoral studies I was a junior
faculty in Baylor for for a year and
then I moved to Roseville for
comprehensive cancer center where I
started my
in class so it's been almost a year now
I have started my own lab okay and tell
me about your lab and the lab people you
can tell a little bit more about that
that would be good
so right now you know after I started
here I have been very fortunate to to
attract a lot of young and dynamic and
self-motivated people to my lab and not
we are still growing and so far it's
been a wonderful journey and I have one
postdoctoral fellow who is working in
the lab right now then I have one
graduate student who officiated joined
the lab excuse me and she is going to
start she's she's gonna do her thesis
work in my lab and then I have and then
I have research technician he is kind at
managing the lab as well as doing a lot
of science and then I have a couple of
students who are rotating in the lab
right now so so far we are almost like
four people in the lab okay and do you
have like you have a very like long
research career of course like it is
grad student postdoc and all those
things can you please talk about some of
the mentors who helped you in your
career in your research and oh
absolutely
so this this this has been you know this
is something which is very important as
you ask because your interest kind of
develops when you're a student and my
interest develop when I was an undergrad
in Bangalore University and I was you
know after few few years maybe in the
first year you still are kind of
exploring what you want to do in your
life and all those options but then you
know suddenly you realize that you you
study something and then you find that
oh I'm so interested in
so my interest started right away at
that time when I I was taught by a very
very very very talented teacher miss
cheetah she took of MicroBot microbial
microbiological biochemistry plus when
when I was in my second year and I once
I I kind of went over the fundamental
biochemistry pathways of metabolic
pathways I was so attracted to it then
even now you know it's almost like
probably the class was a lecture was
taken in 2000 and I was a student in the
year 2000 now it's like almost 18 years
my love has grown bigger and bigger that
now my whole lab is working on that so
so it has been fascinating and and in my
second year of undergrad I realized that
I'm going to start working this way
because I was so so fascinated by those
metabolic enzymes pathways and and so I
decided my masters is going to be in
biochemistry and and I really ought to
mashita who kind of taught that class in
undergrad and after that I I just went
ahead in my third year when I was
finishing my undergrad to kind of only
study biochemistry masters in
biochemistry oh you can realize at that
time biotechnology is kind of like hot
everybody wants to study biotechnology
people were going like to all the
different Institute's to give entrance
tests but I was focused that I want to
do biochemistry and I was very lucky and
fortunate to crack the inference at bhq
by chemistry and I joined me into
biochemistry for my masters and it was a
very short pool of students who were
actually admitted into that it's video
and and they're you know it was
fascinating because at the time I have
like my whole two years on
and I recall a lot of lectures which
then shaped me up like it's more deep
more mechanistic and how you know
there's so many things to do and
lectures from dr. Shrivastava lectures
from dr. Otto over lectures from dr.
Dube you know those and the lectures
which kind of prepared you and at the
time I was kind of like almost distinct
that yes I'm going to study biochemistry
I'm undergoing to the metabolic pathways
but I was not sure like how to shape up
my research right but a short steam in
the industry where also I've worked on
drug discovery for metabolic disorders
which is kind of hard biochemistry and
the pathways and that shaped me up that
there are so many biochemical or
metabolic enzymes and pathways that kind
of integrates into your fundamental
health system and if there is any
problem in those it kind of changes and
results in lot of diseases so so and
then I was fascinated by all those
things and when I entered my graduate
school I I was I was looking kind of
trying to point to a lab where I can
work on those areas I don't know whether
is fortunately or unfortunately but I
did not study too much of my history in
my PhD but I focused mostly on on on
oncogene and and cancer preparation but
I always kept on reading literature's
and things like that so in dr. Jacob
issue anarthas lab who was my graduate
mentor at und Cancer Center at Fort
Worth I kind of exploring many different
areas I did work on a lot of things but
the biggest finding from those was kind
of where we identified novel oncogene
then uncle gene was named as chromosome
17 work 37 at the time so there was not
an official gene name given and I was so
fascinated as a young graduate student
then let's find out
of this gene and it took us a long but
finally we were able to crack it out and
found that this gene is involved in in
my prescient and innovation of cancer
cells and from there you know it was it
was really interesting because then
after our papers came out we were able
to change the name of the gene because
based on the function of the gene is
named as mean one which is migration in
innovation enhancer phone so you can see
like how your basic discovery kind of
changes the whole field but my interest
and my passion on biochemistry still
remained and I was at the time being
trained in cancer biology I got how
about working on cancer metabolism an
area which was at the time kind of
evolving a lot of interesting papers
coming out from outstanding labs and as
a senior graduate student it was kind of
very very interesting to see how these
this pathways kind of now can crossed up
with oncogenes so it's more of studying
the biochemistry of the tumor cells so
that's what I did in my postdoc I went
to an outstanding lab dr. Burt O'Malley
national medal of science laureate and
he has been you know he has wasted all
their words you can imagine and it was
it was fascinating experience for me to
be working so closely with him and even
now like for six to seven years there
and it changed my life because I kind of
you know when you were posed I didn't
know the experiments you know the
techniques you know the things but we
still don't know which science on which
project is kind of like and high-impact
story which is the thing that you want
to study and which other things are are
important for mankind or for the field
okay and that training was outstanding
before and I have been very fortunate
that I have been in that laughs for so
long and being trained
and got the right in not only just a
training but also your mental aspect
where you have to be very strong and
where you have to be always kind of
self-motivated passion toward science
and that's passively and so as you can
see I had something enters out of my
life from my undergrad to my postdoc
training and even now much here who
isn't my mentor because when you start
your own lab you you have to give it to
your people who are helping you and I
have a very good call
renowned scientist who is my chair in
the department and a lot of other people
live in Roswell who are very very very
helpful
so mentors are our pillars of your
success you know because with their
there they have seen the world in so
many different ways and and their the
their strategies and their ideas their
findings kind of shapes you but it's not
always that the mentors and it will be
you have to kind of work with them and
you have to take whatever they're saying
and then kind of up like that so from
now on I think it's my time to give it
back to the students more than where I
have a lot of my mentors and it's it's
been outstanding so far in the graduate
education and things like that and my
mission is to you know just try to have
the students out the way I have been
helped by others and other mentors and
and hopefully we can create a lot of
young talented scientists who will take
the science for good good and you talked
about all these metabolism cancer and
all those things I saw you are the
recent papers and all those things which
was very interesting so let's go back
and see your presentation and if you can
help us understand what you are doing in
the lab that would be really sure
absolutely so what I'm going to do today
is I'm going to talk very briefly about
as you mentioned a recent paper that
came out in nature and I'm going to talk
over it and kind of show you what the
things we are going to do
so can you see the presentation yeah all
right wonderful so so I'm going to talk
about transcriptional control of tumor
metabolic adaptations so as as I told
you that metabolic adaptations are are
occurring the tumor cells and this is
kind of a field where you can see that
the basic biochemical pathways that are
present in every every cell in our body
but in tumor cells these pathways are
altered okay so these pathways are now
are now kind of changed in a way that
allows the tumor cells to succeed not
only in generating a tumor a primary
tumor but also spreading into different
organs a process which is called tumor
metastasis alright so but as you know
that the tumor the cancer progression
process is is a long process it is it
has many different steps it has many
different mechanisms and each each step
is very important for a tumor cell to
succeed and survive in our body so if
you look into the primary tumor here
where you have a lot of tumor cells and
but very few cells are able to come out
of the primary tumor cells invade it
through the XSL euler matrix which is
our tissues and kind of reach the blood
vessels where the tumor cells name in
intra bassett and in the circulation the
tumor cells survive and only very few
tumor cells are able to come out of the
blood vessel and then grow in different
organs so here is a process which we are
calling as what successful tumor
metastasis now what are the things that
allows the tumor cells to survive this
whole process
and if you look into that all throughout
this process from primary team on to
forming a successful maths you have the
tumor cells the most important important
thing that you muscles need is to energy
okay and it's kind of like where you can
see that the energy is the powerhouse of
the tumor cells on which you have all
the different processes of survival
adaptation growth proliferation and
finally if they succeed in all of those
then the tumor spreads to metastasis
that's the spreading to different organs
now if you want to target and and just
just a clinical aspect of it most of the
diseases most of the different types of
teen ones that we have in the clinics
now minister sees is the killer because
this is the this is the form of cancer
that is causing a lot of mortality so we
definitely need to come up with a
solution that we can use to law tumor
metastasis so I kind of put here a very
popular game which is called Zynga where
you know if you want to win this game
you have to kind of somehow dislodge the
base and if your base is very strong
it's very hard to break this apart okay
and in in tumor cells are in this
strategy where you have if you kind of
device a strategy to block tumor
metastasis I think it's very important
to attack the tumor metabolism which is
kind of giving you the energy or the ATP
required for the cancer cells to survive
so how we do that now if we come back to
these different stages or different
process of the cancer progression and
metastasis the requirement for
metabolism is not always the same if
you're looking at the primary tumor
where the tumor cells are kind of
growing all the time it's kind of trying
to
build a big chunk of tumor which is we
call it as a primary tumor
now this primary tumor in this process
of primary tumor formation the anabolic
pathways are very important for the
tumor cells that's that means it's kind
of building up but once the tumor cell
leaves are some of the tumor cells are
able to leave this primary tumor in and
enter into the into the cancer
metastasis and and then enter into the
blood vessels then the tumor cells may
not need that much of energy may not
need that much of anabolic processes to
build up anymore but what is being
taught that in this stage the tumor
cells need to survive so they will they
will make some energy and they will try
to survive and find out all the
different parameters that our human body
has like immune cells apoptotic factors
and so forth and so that they can
survive and then finally few tumor cells
are able to grow in different organs
like nuts leave or upon where the tumor
has now spread from the primary tumor
it's a breast cancer prostate cancer any
different types of cancer now you have
it in your major organs of the lungs
liver and bone then again in this stage
the tumor cells have to change their
missionary the biochemical pathways so
that they can't grow inside these
foreign organs inside these different
organs where they did not originate so
in this stage you need to have this
adaptation where the tumor cells can
altered itself in a way that can use it
the nutrients or the resources available
in this site so what makes these tumor
cells so much worse a time that can it
can alter the metabolic requirements as
it passes from the primate you are to
forming aggressive metastatic disease
and we think that
there are certain different ways that we
can explain these phenotype or this
mechanism there there are many different
types of signaling more cell signaling
processes that takes place one of the
traditional one is what we know in the
literature or what we know in the in the
textbooks that we have a growth factor
or hormone which binds to the receptors
which activates the kindnesses of the
signaling molecules and these molecules
then activate the transcriptional
regulators which turn on genes and if
these are metabolic genes then you have
an increase in the tumor metabolism but
what we think is that in this process of
cancer progression there may be certain
certain different aspects to it where
the nutrients of the metabolites which
are available followed by the tumors are
available for the tumors when they're in
different sites for for example in the
primary side it's in the circulation or
in the different organs these nutrients
kind of acts as the acts as a signaling
molecule which then stimulates various
sensors in the tumor cells now these
sensors can be activated by these
nutrients signaling using protein
modifications enzyme activations
epigenetic marks and this activation of
the sensors kind of leads to the
activation of the genes of the metabolic
enzyme which are required to utilize the
nutrients that kind of act as signal so
you can see here there is a very
specific way of enhancing the
transcription of genes which are
required to utilize that nutrient and
this process gives you a lot of benefits
because you don't want to turn on genes
which are not required at the time and
you want to turn on genes that are very
specifically required for utilizing that
nutrient suppose you have glucose here
if the blue is glucose you will turn on
genes that are required to metal
Lucas but if you have amino acids or
other nutrients such as fatty acids you
will turn on enzymes that are acquitted
like that so cancer cells and I believe
and there are a lot of literature coming
out so far from many different labs
which kind of shows that this minimalist
signaling theory which which is very
very important in cancer cells so when
when I what so what we are doing in our
lab so we are asking very fundamental
research questions in our lab we want to
understand the role of this nutrient
signaling in transcriptional activation
we want to understand what are the
different types of nutrients that can
activate the transcription of specific
genes we are very interested to
understand how this metabolic signaling
sets the stage for metabolic reword that
means how this signaling aspect of how
the nucleons alters the metabolic
metabolic pathways energy ourselves and
most importantly how this metabolic
reburning or switches are regulated in
so then a tumor cell progresses to the
metastasis thing all tumors did not
doesn't progress to metastasis so some
tumors do program some don't so are
there's metabolic switches are there
some metabolic checkpoints which allows
the tumors to be more aggressive and and
we are very interested to understand
this all right so when I was a postdoc
in bartemaeus lab at Baylor College of
Medicine we were very interested in
understanding a molecule which is called
posterior receptor co-activators 3 so
these are molecules which binds to the
transcription factors on nuclear
receptors and when they bind they
activate the genes or they can sometimes
we prints the genes and and we were very
interested to study this molecule called
steroid receptor co-activators Reata
Sarcee 3 please don't confuse it with
sod kinase that's a different molecule
so it is in point 3 or SRC 3 and
previous studies from the lab has shown
that this molecule is very important in
breast cancer or mammary gland
development it covers with oncogenes
like hard to neo also known as erbb2 in
generating resistant tumors and breast
tumors it's one of the most important
molecule if you want to look into that
estrogen response treatment breast tumor
Genesis and most importantly we where
the lab bars lab previously found that
this molecule is heavily modified in and
by post translational modifications
particularly by kinesins and this
modification can have allows this
molecule is RC 3 to find very specific a
little transcription factors and
activate gene transcription so we were
interested and we were trying to
identify the mechanisms and how and
strategies that can use to lock in
certain safely in cancer so that we can
come up with a strategy that can be
utilized in patients now as I said that
it's ours it's reusable
here will be phosphorylated by
clinicians and so we thought that are
getting sse3 alone it may not be very
helpful but if we block insert sofyan
kindnesses together that may give us a
better effect to block breast cancer so
we need to know the kinase is that
modified this SRC 3 so this
phosphorylation of the sources we can be
blocked and if that is blocked then that
molecule will not be able to turn on the
genes so that was a very very very basic
strategy or in a layman term that we
part of doing so it's important for us
to know all the kindnesses are the most
important kindnesses which activates the
cersei 3 by phosphorylating it so that
it turns on the genes and if we can find
that kindness we can block it together
so i started on this project in a
different in a different way because
since we need to know all the kindnesses
that are important for kindnesses that
are important for cross-training sse3 i
started with the library screen so this
is an unbiased way of looking into all
the kindnesses that is possible
innocence III so I used a human kind
kind of library so the human kind kind
of library consists of 636 human
kindnesses excuse me and 636 human kind
is is also for known in our field and so
we have all the different kinda sees and
then we use the library which contains
small interfering RNAs or si or enums
targeting each kind instance and we have
three different assignments for each -
so you can imagine we had almost 2200 si
RA means that we have to screen and
identify which one of them which of the
kinase is regulating associate
reactively so I set up the library
screen using using a couple of different
approaches and I'm going to talk about
the first approach that we did the first
one we used a couple of different
plasmids so we use gal4 DNA binding
domain which is a short molecule which
is fused to SRC 3 and that allows SRC 3
to be to kind of bind to the girl for
binding sites which is present in a
report atmosphere so we have either the
calf container binding fused with the
Circe 3 or we have the report it was
made which contents got for binding
sites so what happens is the calcio TNA
binding domain and SRC 3 is fuse burning
kind of binds here and once this binding
occurs you will see our reporter
activity of Lucy forests now when we are
throwing these plasmids are transfecting
these plasmids inside the cells
there will be phosphorylated by
different kindnesses and and if you use
specific sern against that kind is then
the correlation will be blocked
that will result in an increase or
decrease in the Lucifer's activity so we
use this screening strategy to identify
which Chinese enhances associate
reactivity or which represses asserts
its reactivity and this is the
cumulative data from the from the screen
and you can see that we have many
different kindnesses these are the
kindnesses when blocked or when knocked
down or a lady is rc3 activity is going
up and these are the kindnesses been
blocked sse3 activity is going down and
among them one of the most prominent
kinds are one of the most significant
which significant it down regulated
service its reactivity was pfk before so
we wanted to study what these things
what this kinase is doing and what it is
what's his role and how it is regulating
a service it's reacting so one is pfk
before so beautyrx before is a metabolic
enzyme it is it's not a traditional
protein kinase it's a metabolic enzyme
but it has very unique features it's one
of the few molecules that we have that
has got a kinase domain which transfers
the phosphate group but it also has a
phosphorous domain which kind of takes
out the phosphate group
so the kindness and the phosphorus was
opposite direction so kinase
phosphorylates of protein was for the
deepest feelings of living and this
molecule has Broca's domains together ok
and here it's showing you have the
kinase domain
sorry this is a phosphatase domain and
here you have the kindness to me
traditionally pfk before functions as a
regulator of glycolysis
ok glycolysis is the process where Lucas
is being used up in the cells and it
informs it makes some energy that's ATP
molecules and convert the glucose into
pyruvate now what we obtained before
does is pfk before one verse fructose
6-phosphate one of the intermediate
of the pathway in the fructose to six
responsible and this fructose to 6
bisphosphate is produced in a very small
amount which kind of activates this
molecule or the enzyme called PF k 1r
phosphofructokinase so if you have this
if you have this middle light focus to 6
bisphosphate produced by PF k before you
can keep this pathway activated all the
time so that all the glucose which has
been taken up by the cells is being
utilized and middleman's alright
and once you you because if Lucas is
being utilized or taken up you form our
energy and once the energy is is
restored then what happens is the
hospital's domain of pfk before right
here is activated which then breaks this
molecule 2 plus 2 6 bisphosphate back
into fructose 6-phosphate so there is a
very nice regulation of how much glucose
to be used how much energy is to be used
needed and once the energy is restored
then the process is stopped and pfk
before kind of plays a very important
regulatory part in this in this
metabolic pathway now the question is
why we are seeing this molecule and
regulating a transcriptional activity so
we first wanted to make sure what we
found from the screen is correct
so we use different strategies first SHR
in a strategy to knock down PF k before
we use 2 different in station is 9 and
20 and we can see that we have been able
to block pfk before where we've blocked
P ok before
expression we found that p sr c 3
activity of the transcriptional activity
or the intrinsic transcriptional
activity is reduced once this is renew
so we can say what we found from the
screen is correct when you not done PF k
before there is a decrease in active
what happens if we do the reverse that
means if you overexpress PF k before it
using adenovirus of PF k before so we
use two different doses of Aetna whereas
now you can see there is a very
overexpression and now you have a very
high overexpression of pfk before and
when we do that we can see the activity
of pfk before is increased as well so so
both either you not down activity of
sse3 is going down if you overexpress
you can restore back back to you most
importantly what we power also is that
when we overexpress appear care before
there is a sudden increase in the
history to accordingly okay and we knew
from our past studies in births lab that
this is mostly because of post
translational modifications as we don't
see any changes in the morning so it's
mostly in that translational level so
that must be some modifications which is
allowing the protein to be highly stable
and that's the reason it's probably
level is increased so we wanted to see
how pfk before is regulating this
activity officer c3 and how it is
regulating the protein level a very nice
paper came out from Jason chestnuts lab
and where they show that the pfk before
has a kinase activity okay they use a
recombinant pfk before or pfk b3 and
otherwise so far and the show that the
pfk before has a kindness v-max of 5.06
okay and if them compare the kindness to
bisphosphate is the phosphatase activity
and they found the pfk before has 4.3
that is more of a kinase activity than
the phosphatase and most importantly for
us it is like the recombinant pfk before
has activity so if you make recombinant
pfk before
enzyme and then then we can study what
it is going to SRC 3 so we exactly did
what what we I just said so we mimicked
the enzymatic reaction that pfk before
entails in the inside the cells so it
converts fructose 6-phosphate into
fructose to 6 bisphosphate and then it
Cleaves back the fructose to 6 base was
fed back into fructose 6-phosphate using
is phosphorus so we we mimicked this
reaction in which
in a test view where we added fructose
6-phosphate we added ATP so these are
the molecules needed for its enzymatic
action and then in this in this
situation in this in this condition we
added pfk before enzyme goes on that's
the recombinant enzyme and then we threw
a Circe to the purified protein because
we want to see what it does to a Circe 3
as well and and then after the
information we ran the gels and we found
that in presence of pfk before so here
you have an increasing concentration of
the pfk before enzyme we found that the
SRC 3 is phosphorylated now we have
proved it this with an antibody which
recognizes both phosphorylated serine
and threonine residues so we can see
increasing the concentration of pfk
before in the enzyme reaction we can see
there is an increase in SRC through
phosphorylation so if this is the case
then the questioning is how they
senseiii
is how POF chemical is regulating this
phosphorylation and and what are the
steps on that so to identify that we
need to understand which is the
phosphate donor is the fructose
6-phosphate the phosphate donor or it's
the ATP's of hospital so we did a
similar experiment but here we either
added fructose 6-phosphate or ATP or
combination of both and we found that if
we add just the fructose 6-phosphate
there is not much change with the
increasing concentration of into 6
phosphate it's kind of like the piece of
Labor but once we add ATP added in
increasing concentration we found there
is an increase in the population of SRC
3 and if we add both of them we don't
see any additive effect in fact and a
higher dosage receives phosphate which
is we can't is a decrease in the
Association
so what it suggests to us that the
fructose 6-phosphate is displacing SRC 3
of pfk before suggesting fructose
6-phosphate and user
see three are competing for the
phosphorylation by pfj before and and
this suggests that he says it we may be
a saucer of pfk before and it can
compete with other known substrate like
water 6-phosphate so well the most
important finding is that ATP is the
phosphate donor so ATP is donating the
phosphate to SRC 3 so to confirm that
finding be used now our radio level ATP
which is the gamma phosphate of the ATP
levels with P 32 and we part on the
similar experiment and now we can see
that indeed and an increasing
concentration of pfk before the P 32
which is the gamma P 32 of the ATP is
now transferring to PF k before protein
and you can see there is an increase in
pH a beautiful phosphorylation so these
experiments kind of confirm that indeed
we have k before in certain situations
can phosphor this RC 3 using the the
phosphate group of ATP so now the
question is very impossible this lesson
3 is a big protein we need to identify
besides made Mary phosphorylates SSA 3
so what we did was we used different
fragments of the sir c3 so it's a c3 has
various whole protein domains and we use
those domains we generate a recombinant
domains of each of those fragments of a
sir c3 and then we used them in the
similar reaction that I showed and then
we found that only one domain and that
is the the CID domain or the CBP
interacting domain is being
phosphorylated by SRC 3 so this domain
is where the pfk before is for
phosphorylating a certain say 3 and
that's why you see this bad coming up
when you do the reaction with Peter
ritual so we this domain is right here
so what we did was we performed a mass
spectrometry where a proteomics approach
where you can see which we
show of amino acids in this domain has
been cost-effective get before and we
found a strong pick on on setting 8:57
side so there is a serine residue at the
857 side of this domain and we found
this this side is being phosphorylated
by pfk people now if you want to confirm
that this is the site being
phosphorylated by pfk before then what
we can do is we can mutate this area to
alanine and then we should not see any
false position and that's what we did we
mutated this side to alanine as the
arrow points out and when we do that we
saw that there's no consolation
so this confirmed that say an 857 side
cersei 3 is being possible when there is
only one side so this Manor will like
much easier so that we can then study
what it does and what's the function of
this oscillation on a 33 now previously
also what paper from previous levels
also found that this site may be
prosperity by another kind of scholar 3
and that kind of suggested and this
study suggested it can
this was formation may be linked to
metastasis so we knew that this side is
very important so so first we wanted to
study whether this side is important for
SRC 3 transcriptional activity and when
we used since pfk before is activated by
glucose we use different concentration
of glucose and the 5 or 25 maybe more
and we found that when we have more
amounts of glucose in the cell which
will activate bak before and we found
that this asset reactivity goes up now
if we if we block pfk before and then
give high amounts of glucose the
activity of SRC 3 suppressed suggesting
this that PF can be the glucose
dependent increase in sse3 activities
regulated by period before the if we
also use pfk before
knockdown part then we
use pfk before mutual and then we can
see that clearly that the mutant is also
suppressive to this activity so if you
have the 857 a mutant you can see that
this this does not increase the activity
suggesting then that the 857 site
phosphorylation is very important all
right so basically if you these are this
is the two important findings that in
presence of glucose the activity of
essentially increases which is dependent
pfk before if you mutate this side to
857 a then you you don't see the
phosphorylation okay all right now then
what we did was if what happens if you
can make a unique that is 857 which kind
of mimics the charges and then we find
that indeed this was this this side now
can increase the activity of sshe so the
next question that we wanted to study is
what are the domains in in pfk before
that are important for regulating this
function and what we knew from the
literature that there are certain sites
which is G 46 P 48 and G 51 these are
the signs which is important for ATP
binding and when we mutated this to
al-amin we found the phosphorylation on
SRC 3 is significantly reduced all right
so this is just again that the
phosphorylation on assertion two is
dependent on the PF chemical binding
tool adp because that's the molecule
which is donating the phosphor and this
again correlates with the PSS its
reactivity so if you have a mutated way
of care before now you don't see the
associates reactivity being increased
whereas when you have a wild-type okay
before you can see this as its
reactivity is increased so not next we
wanted to study whether
pfk before can also regulate the
estrogen signal in the similar way and
we found indeed when pfk before
is in presence of glucose the activity
associate increases by pmk before but if
you not done sse3 the ER activity goes
down so this suggests that it's our c3
phosphorylation by via cable is
important for exactly will be in here
cause big tumor cells as well and this
also correlates very nicely with the
growth curve so if you have not done as
I say three you don't see the tumor cell
screen if you have the reacts press the
wall types associating in rescue that
you know cell growth but if you have a
mutant 8:57 a you don't see much of
growth so suggesting it came the 857 a
857 side phosphorylation is important
for achievements of survival next we
wanted to see what happened to us as day
three when it is stimulated with glucose
and since pfk before is regulating the
glucose enzyme we stimulate the tumor
cells with different concentrations of
glucose and the five millimolar are
twenty five meeting over and we found
the fossil a tion and the setting equal
to seven significantly increased when
when you have 25 milli molar or high
amounts of glucose and if you withdraw
this gluten so W B stands for withdraw
and if you get other glucose the
phosphorylation is videos or if you're
not done here K before the
phosphorylation now is gone so this
suggests that tumor cells which are
dependent on high amounts of glucose
they will have an increase in pfk before
activity
this will phosphatase a c3 and this will
increase the transcriptional activity so
the question then comes what's the
function significance what are the
target genes how it regulates this
activity and then what it causes and
whether this pathway is important for
cancer filtration so we portion of
metabolomics experiment where you try to
identify all the common metabolize that
are changed by pfk before a cell c3 and
we found very surprisingly that measure
D of the meta moments that are changed
for that pfk before sir c3
are related to the molecules that are
important for DNA synthesis so these are
computing and the periods of the
molecules which are important for DNA
synthesis and when we looked into this
pathway we found that indeed the purine
synthesis is kind of connected with
glucose our glycolytic pathway and when
we looked into the different enzymes and
we found there are three important
enzymes that are regulated by PA table
processes signaling which fits nicely
into this pathway so that suggests that
this molecule is this thing this
important processor between metabolic
enzyme and the transcriptional
correlator
is regulating the flow of the glucose
from graduated pathway into the pinion
paracentesis
alright and and that may be important
for the tumor cells to survive and grow
in different stages either during the
adaptation stage or during the survival
stage so then this is this is little bit
very important experiment where we try
to confirm this hypothesis that the
glucose card bones are actually
regulated by pfk before to enter into
the purines so what we did was we we
check whether the pfk before is
regulating the sucrose flow into the
internet into the peering synthesis and
this takes place by a metabolic pathway
which is called as pentose phosphate
pathway or PPP so we used glucose which
is level at the sixth position so we
call them as 1613 nickels and if that
happens the cells will then take up the
glucose utilize it and even have the
pentose phosphate pathway intermediate
ribose 5-phosphate level at the fifth
position all right so now when you knock
that bfk before now we are seeing that
the right will be right ready those five
phosphate c-13 incorporation
significantly decrease so suggesting
that when you don't have pfk before the
flow from here to here is
all right so that suggests that the
glucose carbon is entering here with the
help of it and this glucose carbon then
over the time will enter into the
purines where now we measure and inosine
one of the products and we found and
indeed the carbon incorporation into
that in the same which is coming from
vehicles is is significantly decreased
when you don't have to be a chemical so
BF came before prison called regulates a
very important flow of the glycolytic
flux into the pentose phosphate pathway
leading to the synthesis of periods and
then we looked into how they appear
before an assertion three together can
regulate the regulate the gene
transcription so we found that there are
certain sites where pfk before binds and
they found that this binding overlaps
with the transcription factor called atf
for and and this side is present in all
the genes that we identify are important
for the period synthesis so now x tht
que tiene MPD one has all those mining
sites where it here for this
transcription factor can find and the
binding of the transcription factor
overlaps with associate 3 pointing right
here suggesting the necessity 3 and atf
put together can regulate this
transcription factors and
transcriptional genes so so we first
started whether ATF or an imposter
sitting interacts and we found indeed in
high Blacula conditions we have increase
in the binding of atf for with
phosphates RC 3 and when you don't have
PF k before this binding is reduced so
suggesting clearly that the phosphates
are three which is the active molecule
regulating the transcriptional function
of a 33 is interacting with the
transcription factor 84 and this binding
is also found on the chromatin so this
is a cheap experiment where we found
that in in presence in in our in in high
amounts of glucose which is driving this
pathway
there is an increased occupancy of ATF
port on the promoter of one of the
target genes from a trans catalyst and
increase in the phosphorus its
recruitment of the promoter so this is
kind of shown here in the schematic so
you have increased amounts of glucose
uptake for the tumor cells pfk before is
activated in phosphorus sse3 ssse3 then
goes to the nucleus where it's in that
it's in the Kumari it minds and
interacts with ATF for which we are
showing here and there together then
regulate the transcription of the genes
which is important for synthesis
appearance so how this pathway is
important in breast tumor progression so
we use mouse model here when we injected
the breast tumor cells in the mammary
fat pad of the mouse and then after six
weeks ago we found that the tumors have
grown bigger so what we did was we took
out the primary tumor out and using
surgery in the mouse and allow the
animals to survive and then after four
weeks of the surgery so four weeks
post-surgery then we try to see the
mouse and see whether any tumor cells
have been able to create metastasis in
different organs so we focused mostly on
the lungs because these animals get not
metastases very quickly so this was our
strategy to see whether if this happens
what is the importance of pfk before
necessary in this process and so if you
look into the primary tumor when we have
not done as I say three or pfk before
the primary tumors isolated from mouse
are very very less very smaller and when
you overexpress SRC 3 that you must grow
bigger and if you if you have a mutant
that is caesarean 8:57 mutant then you
see the tumors are very small so this
suggests clearly that the pfk before in
associates we are very important for
forming the priority emergencies and the
8:57 side phosphorylation is critical
for this pathway
next we then focused on the second part
that is after we resected the primary
miss out we waited and try to see what
happens to the two to the animals
whether they are getting any mats or not
and then after four weeks when we looked
into the lungs this is about innocence
engaging so our tumor cells have been
leveled with vociferous and we can see
clearly that the one tech team worse
with the cersei 3 there is an increase
in lung expand as shown in pathology
here and when we have a mutant 8:57 a or
pfk before insertion through being
suppressed or a plated you don't see
that much of meds you don't see much
here in the bioluminescence and
pathology we do see some small nodules
but a very very less compared to the
tumors that have one type of sorcery so
this is the present demographically here
so all these studies kind of suggest
that the phosphorylation of 8:57 side
officer c3 is very important so we then
looked into the primary tumor and try to
see the animals which developments do
they have a three to seven side possible
so we used an antibody which recognizes
the eight people inside and we can
clearly see that the 857 side is four
heavily phosphorylated as recognized by
the antibody and they are mostly inside
the nucleus so because we know they
traditional phosphorylation is important
for gene transcription of vomiting so we
can see clearly the March is showing us
that they're mostly in the nucleus and
this is a human tumor growing inside the
mouse and the antibody specificity
clearly shows that it is only picking
out the tumor area which is the human
cells not the mouse so it shows you very
nice specificity and if you block a cert
III of course you don't see if you block
the kinase you also don't see the
confirmation so this purely suggests
that the tumors which developments later
on have an increased amount of
confirmation
in 57 which is in the nucleus and
regulating the process of plants
so in a summary what I have shown you is
that glucose which is the traditional
glycolytic pathway here glucose to
pyruvate gives you energy and here now
we found there is sudden changes in the
tumor cells where and political
regulator of fear of this pathway pfk
before is now activating transcription
by postulating SRC 3 this phosphatase RC
3 then binds to a tier 4 and vigorous
transcriptional genes
t kt MP d 1x age and that allows the
synthesis of purines purines are very
important macromolecules required for
the tumor cells to grow and survive and
as a result you can see there is an
increase in energy growth and
proliferation and Mets so next we tried
to identify what happens to the patients
because it's important that whatever you
find in the lab it has to be somehow
related clinically so we we identified
we got some tumor tissues from the
normal from the tumors from the patient
tumors so these are the T represents the
patient tumors and in represents
adjoining normal tissues okay and we had
like 14 patients so 7 here and 7 years
of total 14 and we can see that mostly
in the to the pfk before level is
significantly elevated in the tumors
compared to the adjoining normal areas
okay majority of the patients and that
correlates very nicely with the
phosphorylation of SRC 3 so this bands
showing here the possible issues of sse3
is increased when you have pfk beautiful
kind of what we where we found from all
more study and if we do a correlation
pfk before all the phosphorus III we do
see there is a nice correlation a
pinnacle correlation so this design this
is showing that impatient tumors as well
the pfk before increase appear capable
increases the cost pollution of
necessity
similarly we also found in another
different types of breast cancer which
is called triple negative breast cancer
that the patients which have increased
amount of pfk before associated together
which is shown here in red their
survival is very low so the patients
don't survive the treatment strategies
and whatever and the patients have a
very poor survival so they the mortality
rate is really high if you have high
amounts of pfk before sse3 whereas the
patients with low amounts of pfk before
necessarily three they tend to do better
so again suggesting is this this pathway
is very important for for the tumor cell
survival and if you can block this so we
probably will be able to ship this car
up there and the patients may survive it
so that's what we are hoping so so in
summary what I have shown you here is
that glucose and nutrients activate this
enzyme pfk before which is a very very
important regulatory enzyme in the
process of Dracula's is it possible it's
a sustained three which we found and
this population of SRC 3 then drives I
hear positive tumors which we have shown
in the patients that they have high
amounts of hospice or so 3 and pfk
before and it also regulates with ATF
for it also drives target genes such as
the purine synthesis genes and all
together it promotes of besting or
probation to marry primary tumor growth
and medicine cells so that is what we
found here all right
so with this I'd like to thank the
people in my lab this is my lab group
and then a lot of help as most of the
work was done when I was at Baylor and
then we finished the work when I moved
to Roseville and thank my mentor Bert
O'Malley all my collaborators and the
funding sources all right with this I'd
like to thank you for giving me this
opportunity to talk about our recent
findings thanks.thanks to work can you
just I have a couple of questions if you
don't work words
just stop sharing so it's a very very
nice presentation thank you so much I
really appreciate that I have couple of
year ago in the list right
during the screen a bunch of molecules
like came up so and from your eventual
result that okay it is you can prevent
the metastasis but still you see in the
histology few things that means like
there is some alternative pathway also
so are you looking into other things in
addition to what you have done so far
yes so there are couple of strategies a
couple of explanations for those answer
the first of all we have two we are now
trying to see whether there are other
strategies that we can use to block is
inside period J knockdowns that the
strategy that we used we were able to
not but we were not able to completely
enough and there are some levels of pfk
before there which may be resulting in
some mats of course there may be some
other pathways some that's why we see
the resistance too many therapies you
know any new drug comes up you say that
the patients respond better but over the
time the business comes down but again
it relaxes after a few few years and
that is a big boy so we are definitely
looking into that so we are looking into
when we don't have pfk before how the
tumor cells tries to compensate the
mechanism okay so we are looking into
that we we are also trying to do that
can be can be used a combinatorial
therapy with some other molecules which
we know that works in the clinics you in
addition to period before SS inhibitors
and use those combinatorial therapist
okay so we are looking into that in
triple negative breast cancer looking
into whether pfk before and SS if we
targeting those two molecules and better
the chemotherapy because patient
sometimes can't resist and intimate
electives so we are trying to see if we
block this pathway if you go up the
escape upwards of the tumors can we now
enhance the the treatment regiment
specificity and the efficacy
I have one more last question this SRC
like the glycolysis happens in the
cytoplasm and as you have shown SLC
moves into the nucleus right for all the
things whatever like I gene expression
and all those things so certainly you
would have found some translocation
domain in SRC nuclear translocation
domain or anything so would it be
possible to block it so that it doesn't
go into the nucleus to activate well
yeah this this is a good question this
has been this has been I would say a lot
of people have tried that which is since
the co-activators are important inside
the nucleus to regulate gene expression
is there a way that we can block it from
entering the nucleus so that the
expression of target genes are not
activated okay there are some problems
with that first of all we still don't
know whether if we mutate this
phosphorylation site can we keep sse3 in
the in the solution that study has not
been done yet so we are definitely
looking into it now the glycolytic
expression the black bonuses are the
regulation of the glucose flow into the
purines it's mostly done by pfk before
not by a certain few cell c3 is mostly
kind of in the nucleus where is
regulating the transcription of the
genes we we definitely are trying to see
when we have some limiters in an
actually the common is that has some
hitters against sse3
which parts in different types of tumors
so this is exactly what we are trying to
see whether we can block as a supreme
act
so that the transcription of the genes
are you pressed okay thank you so much
I really appreciate your time and effort
and look forward to more of your
publications in the near future in some
of the reputed journals again well thank
you so much for having me here it's a
great opportunity to be talking to you
and I wish you all the best in this
mission thank you thank thank you I'll
keep in touch with you and it will be on
our site within next few minutes
basically as soon as we are done
I send you a link also okay thank you so
much thanks uber